we have breaking news and that is that
Finland is to join NATO this Tuesday it
initially came from The Finnish
president's office saying that it will
officially become a member of the NATO
military Alliance on Tuesday and then in
the last few minutes Jens stoltenberg
has confirmed that Finland is to join
NATO on Tuesday so a bit of background
um
Finland has been fairly neutral when it
comes to Nato you'll know Finland has a
huge border with Russia and what we were
waiting for after the invasion with
Ukraine that neutrality obviously
changed and what will what NATO and
Finland were waiting for was for the
Turks to give the go-ahead because they
initially delayed the bid to join NATO
and then we got that go ahead on Friday
Philip Ingram is here now he's obviously
you know him he's a military analyst
this is a big deal isn't it having
Finland officially joining NATO on
Tuesday given that huge border with
Russia and their history with the
Russians it's a very big deal you know
Finland has for many years tried to stay
neutral because of its border with
Russia and the the way it would
um have impacted on this relationship
with Russia and after Russia's illegal
reinvasion of Ukraine if Finland has
examined its defensive posture and
decided that actually would be stronger
to be part of NATO and then we had that
issue with Finland and turkey and turkey
was you're trying to negotiate further
um
relationships with Finland and and
issues with them as happens with any
um International negotiations that are
going on but this is significant because
Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine because
he didn't want Ukraine to become closer
to the West they've come closer to Nato
NATO is now expanding because of it and
that's always the the argument isn't it
um that the Russians and their allies
have said oh well NATO was on Russia's
doorstep well now it is and it wasn't
going to be had he not invaded Ukraine
exactly and we've now got you know
thousands of kilometers of border with
Russia there have been Neto flights with
their surveillance aircraft going up
over Finnish airspace in recent weeks
that gives NATO a much greater reach to
see into Russia much more interesting so
it will give a lot to Nato having the
fins oh it's part of the alliance huge
amount I'm militarily Finland is very
very strong indeed it's a very capable
military prescription don't they
um I'm not sure whether they still have
conscription
um but they've got a very professional
military capability I've worked with
some of them in different overseas
operations they've worked with NATO they
they think operate and can integrate
very very quickly indeed and they do
have such a strong military because of
that history with Russia don't they and
they feel that they have to be very
strong because they've got the Russians
on their doorstep well they suffered you
know a Russian invasion back in the
second world war and they lost a big
chunk of Finnish territory so they they
understand exactly what's going on
inside Ukraine at the moment and you
know they held the a massive massive
Russian military back during the second
world war and negotiated the uh you know
a settlement but they did lose some
territory in doing that so they've got a
bit of a score to settle so what would
it mean militarily
um that they are joining on Tuesday well
militarily what it means is Russia now
has got
um you know they see Russia as this big
bad wolf that is focusing on trying to
do harm to Russia NATO is a defensive
organization it's it's there to defend
against anyone attacking into into
native countries but defend from a
collective perspective but Russia will
see this as a potential aggressive move
and it will split their defensive forces
and they're going to have to move more
up
um into the the area around Finland
because they'll see that as a greater
NATO threat and they'll be watching very
closely as to you know how Finland
integrates its military and its
capabilities in with NATO and and what
they're doing there
how long do you think that would take
it could happen you very very quickly
indeed Finland has been on exercises
with Neto they've been deployed with
NATO they think the same way the
communications will work
um it's it's going to take a little
while for some of the processes and
procedures to come in and some of the
documentation to be
re-stamped NATO classified rather than
necessarily just finished classified but
they could operate tomorrow so NATO come
Tuesday just got bigger and stronger oh
very much so very much so and Vladimir
Putin will want to do something
um to try and Mark that occasion and it
will probably do something inside
Ukraine it wouldn't surprise me if we
see more rocket attacks and other things
inside Ukraine okay interesting Philip
thank you so much thank you